this all day kitty boy yeah yeah alright
what this ain't [ __ ] oh hey both do you
remember during our big mood podcast
shoot that you mentioned this one chick
that she went really viral on tick-tock
well is it the okay boomergirl yeah oh
dude
she makes me hate myself she's so bad
she's so pretty I catch me outside then
no no no like like hot-hot bad yeah
she's like the only girl that I've seen
go viral so quickly just for being hot
Wow
so her name or like at least her handle
it's Nicole oh oh that's a weeb [ __ ]
yeah she's a we she weed
what's a weed like super like I love
Japanese anime I love anime everything
enemy all the time I want it does do a
lot of anime things what does it stand
for
Oh weeble where's that stanton
definitely something about white people
obsessed with [ __ ] Japanese called so
we don't know what that stands for
it's just a word for yeah pedestrians
laying for a [ __ ] person walking
through the pricing me walk the guy
walks like obsessive Korean would be
Korea boo I don't know what the word
actually comes from but yeah for context
this is the the okay boomer video that
made her viral oh yeah cutie pie she's
super cute here we go
[Music]
okay I can if she wasn't cute and she
did that video that what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this job yeah yeah it's just
because she's cute I can admit that was
nothing that that's look like nothing
I can't imagine all the basement
dwellers just [ __ ] wanted to lick her
toes her and she literally posted a
picture where she was just like what's
up huh better and it's like just but
it's just got like a hundred thousand
light you know minute I can see it she
said she likes Bernie and he was
probably 67 when she was born
it's just the birds are so fun oh dude I
can see it I can see it all the white
nights is that one there are some good
boobs really made all those the boobs
are those like the cami that already has
the cups in it cuz I should go be
playing those are some titties like you
would know do we know that if it's
built-in if its target cuz look like I
see like an outline picture I'm just
saying I'm not salivating the way I
would it for those were like legit legit
I want to hear no no I would dare I'm in
fooled so often feet man okay he's got
good titties
she's got a nice body that looks less
padding TIF look you can see the [ __ ]
hat away the titty yeah oh that's patty
Fox this pic it's a [ __ ] expose video
okay could be padding like knit it
doesn't matter I can call that [ __ ] from
across the street
O'Brien superpower my man this it really
is such a burden turns well it is cuz
now I have to compliment you like I know
that's yours and I know it's not
tracking so do you think if you have one
yeah I never seen them say here you were
natural I don't care how big
although I prefer natural anything over
my polish spillage anyway this is this
all out there on the side anyway I don't
I don't care about that like I just like
I like women's body that's it I
appreciate what you bring it to the
table you don't matter how big or how
small it is I'm [ __ ] with you like a
copy the whole team I put that whole
thing I stuff it in between my lip and
my gum
if there's not make it fit if there's a
whole thing I might as well fit you
can't fit it if it's saline you doesn't
fold the same it's not it does not true
I love natural boobs
I like stretch marks I love I love
running my tongue along heel stretch
mark I love all let's hit yo Gotti's
beautiful baby girl let somebody tell
you different our [ __ ] would you like a
condom you record that and put it on
only fans yeah oh my god yeah they got a
paint they got a pen yeah Godzilla yeah
you can't just get this uplifted for
free who the [ __ ] am I Gandhi is always
free psycho we move in a new very good
even if it's inspirational that's it
with coke coke booty hole were you I
don't I don't lick coke I just just a
bump what's that called buddy hall I was
seeing how if he would look in okay
maybe it was covered nobody do an effort
gone way I would do a line of coke off
of your butthole
oh that's really sweet thank you very
much lightweight light like fresh out of
the shower out the butthole I just got a
home for the day but you'd say which one
you put right there man so do we know
what she's no Guinea she's really cute
okay it turns out there were these
screenshots of socialblade circulating
around looks just like a straight-up
spike no the opposite here it says that
she lost about 60,000 followers in one
day after during one of her life's dream
like the twitch streams she mentioned
she had a boyfriend
Oh
Melanson have you dumb [ __ ] thought you
had a chance
oh my god people thought oh they weren't
there for Bernie what platform is that
on Twitter oh my god you know what I
like me doing my own research not just
the article stuff I'm I pulled up my own
social blade stuff and those numbers
aren't there so I am confused because as
of right now she still has two hundred
and twenty-seven thousand Twitter
followers and there were other
screenshots saying that she only had
like fifty nine thousand or some other
stuff so I don't know how true this is
it seems like it's just a glitch and
then somebody made a big girl for me
could be the YouTube does that thing
where it dumps certain amount of people
every month or so when it cleans out X
subscribe let me tell you something
actively counsel the overall population
does not care about your happiness we
love what people are going through it
when they're looking for that special
one and where they're [ __ ] up that's
why people will do so well on albums
when they just got out of relationship
some [ __ ] like that
like when chance came up with this last
album and he was like I love my wife and
he was promoting happiness and positive
vibes
nobody was [ __ ] with that we don't
give a [ __ ] about your happiness it's
like first album infidelity brought that
up that in infinite he had a lot of
happy songs feels really soft and he was
like he had songs that were like you
could be king you could be a star no
matter whoever you are you could be
anything it's all you baby
nobody [ __ ] box that's because that
was a harbor right yeah that should just
suck like that Reading Rainbow [ __ ] you
thank you thank you
everyone's almost like I wanted L sad
weekend and said janae I do want to do
any but you know what it's because
misery loves company we like when
they're like that because we feel less
fucked-up about ourselves yeah I think
there's also the mass appeal of it
because I would say that there are
they're more single people than people
in happy relationships or fucked-up
relationships and single but then also
happiness like it sounds kind of dumb
but like I think like happiness doesn't
have a lot of depth or passion to it
it's just it's up there but action and
sadness it goes deep and it goes deeper
there's so many things that can bring
you said I need lana del rey in a bumpy
car doing her [ __ ] album I don't need
this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no because you see
that mean the puppet give my man the
bumpy cobblestone [ __ ] Street I need
already as bumpy as possible car built
in 1907 with no no yes no shocks yes no
shot take it away take away the [ __ ]
suspension that she's like you drive me
crazy heavy walk if she runs over a
crack I want I want her neck to be
broken
thank you I want to [ __ ] hear
intervals up okay so don't give me this
Lawndale rank [ __ ] on a gyroscope
[ __ ] don't give me this photo with your
boyfriend [ __ ] I will I will admit that
like if I follow a chick for four like
her a B and like the vacation pictures
and [ __ ] like that and then she post a
picture of her kid kills the fantasy oh
your eyes it makes it so real
yeah have a second page for that [ __ ]
recently uh but I ended up posting
photos being KC and then I cut at the
end thing like get that [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of here
way too much of you your man I have to
unfollow you I'm like bye that's how I
feel I'm like ah Jackie [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're Casey all over your page oh I
thought you meant that's how you feel
cause like on my channel with Mo but
then Cibrian's been all infiltrated tell
me about it people are like I subscribed
for Nikki limo not Nikki and Steve
oh my there's people that are like older
come here for Steve I got people were
like hey man I miss your old edge man
like you don't do the same [ __ ] used to
do because of Nikki man I'm like look
this is not cuz of me [ __ ] cute
[ __ ] YouTube algorithm [ __ ] peace
out dude
exactly yeah I'm like okay
but it's not cousin Nikki I'm glad
somebody finally answered my question
although I did stop him from doing a few
trolls where he would have gotten cute
too but you know I got killed for what
you need though like I feel like I feel
like all guys are just like I'll just on
this this path to destruction yeah and
then we have to come in and we're like
wow what do you do the men die
immediately ask immediate friends who
told who were in the military who told
me I would have died if I'd done this
one thing I was gonna do I think he
saved me from so I think I am a lot we
got in a huge fight about huge fight
because it was just like the soul of the
universe spoke through me I was like
fine we do whatever you want I'm not the
type of girl that's gonna like infringe
upon whatever year you want to do
basically but then also on the day as he
was leaving to go to this shoot I was
like you can't go I mean he was like
what and I was like no no no you can't
go because if you do this and I'm gonna
be in danger and you're gonna be in day
time we're all going we're all gonna get
killed or nope I got to break up with
you if you do this oh [ __ ] tomato and
we'd be together for like a year or two
at that point and I was like it's not
meant to be no tomatoes I'm telling you
if you go to this shoot I have to break
up with you
wait what was that what happened I can't
say I'm camera killed just for the
Yankees you know we would have gotten he
would have gotten killed for sure I
might have been in the line of fire
we're gonna talk about this afterwards I
will say absolutely all I'll say is that
it had some news drawn my life and
that's it you say draw your life the
trend when trend would draw my life was
going on this is when I was I was gonna
do this okay wait wait can we just can
we just try to give her something yeah
luckily at the end of the video so
perfect timing
okay goodbye
[Music]